c'est ici à champ fleuri que se trouve
l'agencé française de développement
un établissement public présent dans le
monde entier qui met en oeuvre la
politique de la france en matière de
développement et de solidarité
internationale ici à la réunion l'afd
soutien plus particulièrement d'une part
la transition environnementale et
écologique et d'autre part la transition
démographique et sociale concrètement
cela signifie que l'afd soutien finance
les acteurs publics et les acteurs
privés dans le domaine de ces
transitions l'afd engage plus de 14
milliards d'euros dans le monde avec
notamment 1072 nouveau projet de
développement soutenu en 2019
le partenariat idéal pour les actions de
coopération de la collectivité
départementale
[Musique]
c'est ainsi le même schéma avec nos
voisins mauriciens et à port louis c'est
une réunionnaise qui nous accueille la
réunion elle est là la vie à l'île
maurice
très agréable
j'apprends à découvrir mon île à travers
les yeux théoricien également en 2018
martin guichard était alors en contrat
unique d'insertion de coopération
internationale le département lui a
donné l'occasion d'ouvrir les portes de
ligne a aussi argué je travaille sur le
programme de renforcement des capacités
commerciales donc en lien avec du cci
chambre de commerce d'occident rien si
je pense que je suis au bon endroit avec
une bonne personne
[Musique]
direction le ministère des services
publics de l'énergie
ici la coopération a pour thématique
nous
[Musique]
si ce sujet central c'est que dans ce
pays il au compte de nombreux acteurs
ressources en eau eau d'assainissement
biodiversité aquatique
personne ne centralise et leurs actions
oui maurice vous savez comment comme
d'autres pays mais avons des challenges
dans les monts texte changement
climatique
il ya beaucoup des problématiques dans
le secteur vous et ça concerne en termes
de quantité et qualité et nous apprenons
que la réunion a beaucoup d'expérience
on savait que le département de la
réunion avait de vraies compétences et
avait déjà créé un office de l'eau et
donc il était question que de mettre en
relation les besoins des acteurs
mauricien avec les compétences et la
valeur ajoutée du département de la
région le département valorise ainsi sa
propre expertise
le fils de l'eau avec plus de 20 ans
d'expérience et un opérateur historique
de cette collectivité qu'on a d'abord
cherché à savoir quelles étaient leurs
besoins et comment il était structuré et
ensuite on a vu avec eux
les données dont il dispose et pour
effectivement regarder si elle répondait
ou pas au à leurs attentes à court et à
moyen terme ce système là va devoir
récupérer les données de 1 2 3 4 2 au
moins cinq entités parra ministériel on
peut évidemment pas arriver en disant
voilà ce qu'on fait à la réunion donc
voilà ce que vous devez faire c'est
vraiment un écueil à éviter dans la
coopération faire oeuvre commune et le
principe même de la coopération mais
alors quel est l'intérêt commun si on
gère bien l'eau et si on anticipe les
questions climatiques à la réunion à
maurice et à rodrigues
effectivement les suivis qui peuvent
être faits là bas peuvent aussi nous
nous renseigner sur ce qui nous attend
nous ici et inversement
il faut je pense ne pas se limiter aux
notions de solidarité qui sont
importantes mais ce sont aussi des
termes de partenariats et c'est à
travers je dirais la coopération entre
les peuples de la zone océan indien de
l'indien de salinité que l'on va
développer réellement une notion
d'intégration régionale économique
sociale la manière de de prendre en
considération des problèmes communs et
d'essayer de les régler ensemble en
mutualisant nos moyens et dans ce
contexte le territoire de la réunion a
de très grands grands atouts à mettre en
avant évidemment en termes de
d'expertisé de plateaux techniques de
capacités de projection qui n'existe pas
ailleurs dans la zone océan indien sud
ouest anticipé est clairement ici
l'enjeu de ce partage des expertises
car c'est coopération tels que celle de
l'eau sont des ressources vitales que
nous partagerons toujours